but can you recommend the five or ten
top films someone should see to get a
great feel of the evolution of
filmmaking suppose they had a weekend
and they said I'm going to sit down and
watch 10 films that Professor curse has
recommended what are they well I
certainly would like you to watch just
some George as magical movies like
Cinderella or any of the sort of a trip
to the moon a trip to the moon would be
a fabulous introduction to the magical
side of filmmaking I'd like you to watch
some kind of classic documentary the
nuclear the North would be good or the
great white light would be good from the
20s films which attempt to look
realistically and honestly at the world
even though he always fail so it want
you to do those two things I'd love you
to watch something like them Jean Figo's
that's a that's a lot to see what French
poetic realism was like I'd love you to
watch one of the Italian neo-realist
movies Bicycle Thief I'd like you to
watch something with the NuWave Truffaut
then I'd like you to watch after that
maybe you know with something like
Apocalypse Now and moving on you know
maybe even Being John Malkovich and I
think in that kind of trip you would
have seen movie history play out pretty
richly I suppose there could have been
some detours there when we in 1927 1928
when we had that fantastic sort of
junction of silence and sound a
wonderful silent film which shows what
happened to silent movies when they
turned into talkies is a movie called
lonesome by Paul vhosts which is it's
primarily a silent movie it's about a
boy and girl young man and one woman who
run off to Coney Island
where I spent many hours because my
grandpa had a store in Coney Island and
it's a beautiful Sorbo meets girl boy
loses girl silent movie but in the
middle of it suddenly but this is 1928
they decided they had to shoot some
sound scenes and their clunky their
ridiculous the preposterous it's like
you know somebody's grading a finger
over blackboard and it just demonstrates
if you want to understand why it was
that filmmakers said oh I don't want to
go to sound it was that kind of thing so
that day that range of movies I think
would be would be a wonderful
introduction to just what happened in
movie history
you